when I'm slow and also just talking
talking way too much then there's no
guarantee what's whatsoever that I'm
gonna be such a strong player worthless
okay let me try the black King another
Turkish player and I am Oh Queen before
where it was the story here so what are
you supposed to do here is black I don't
know I see nobody certainly doesn't help
okay Queen c7 just trying to make and b5
if I feel like this is some sort of
theory maybe a
[ __ ] law
don't know but at least I get to castle
and it looks fairly reasonable for me at
some point I want to go before but I
gotta keep in mind that he always has
c4s a reply so just special base sex
you
this one I'm not convinced about can't I
go before now
we got some interesting tactics coming
potentially after 95 but I think I'm
doing fairly well there and if see for
that just drops upon to 94 94 opening up
for it the Queen to protect the sea
forest so I can just go Bishop see
before that can his green winning upon
with a great position so I think might
be five is forests
Oh a Suckerfish bath too
my case that would have been very
interesting okay
he could go queenie one as well but I
sort of discounted that um just rent
general grounds because I thought I
would have a very nice position here
with complete control over d5 and with
opponent I fine that means that he has
very very little attacking potential on
the kingside because that that pawn on
f5 gives me a lot of space on the Kings
side usually opponents on f7 and 95
queenie for it could happen and so on
so this looks very very good for me just
age six I guess
go away Knights didn't see rook c1 but
that's not a it's not a major worry
Queen a8 don't know if there's any
massive points but I've learned I
learned since I was little that putting
the Queen's
in the corner is something that Grand
Master's do
I was inspired to start doing it myself
let me see
- hinting at Bishop h6 which is
me a little bit okay
I'm gonna believe him maybe he was
bluffing but I'm gonna believe it
okay I gotta play faster so I'm not
loving this double exchange but I just
got a black pastor at some point at the
very least I'm hoping this way if he
does take I could potentially change the
position of of the Queen and the bishop
rights and get I'm gonna take this go
Bishop f3 yeah and exactly get the Queen
to c6 while the Bishop Austin b7
obviously not with the bishop on on f3
that's never gonna happen but now at the
earliest I'm winning upon since I was a
king both D 2 and a 2 sorry D four and A
two and now with the pawn up this should
be winning would be five doesn't work I
believe okay
Queen D phallic prohibition t5z Venezia
and yeah here's his fighting admirably
with with g4 but I think it's destined
to is destined to fail
don't want to give him gf than Bishop d3
and get f5 and then d7 so I'm just just
keeping control in this way instead
don't give him a glimmer of hope
yeah once again don't even don't even
calculate calculate the complicated
lines just keep it simple
yeah I can just run with the king oh I
gotta I gotta mind the time a little bit
Jack Jack
there is no maids but I can win the
bishop so rooks e7 will serve a trickier
try but I could also win the bishop
there okay he's gonna he's gonna make a
serious attempt to fling me here so I
gotta I gotta speed it up
there was a serious attempt at flagging
wow that was pretty close he feared gun
if you're gonna eat seven there he would
have liked me
holy smokes in my slow